IN THE SENATE WE'RE WATCHING
FOUR CRITICAL RACES ARIZONA,
NEVADA, WISCONSIN.
IT TAKES 51 TO WIN AN OUTRIGHT
MAJORITY.
WE HAVE REPORTERS AND
CORRESPONDENTS SPREAD OUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY MONITORING THE
CLOSEST RACES.
IN NEVADA CATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO
IN A TOSS UP WITH ADAM LAXALT.
WE ARE STILL WAITING ON AN
ESTIMATED 20% OF VOTES TO BE
REPORTED IN NEVADA.
ROSA FLORES JOINS US LIVE FROM
LAS VEGAS.
STILL EARLY, WHAT IS THE LATEST?
>> Reporter: WELL, ANDERSON,
BOTH CAMPAIGNS VERY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THEIR CHANCE AT WINNING
THIS SEAT.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THE INCUMBENT
ST
SENATOR CATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO,
AN ENDANGERED DEMOCRAT, PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST ENDANGERED
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE, HER
CHALLENGER ADAM LAXALT, THEY
WERE CAMPAIGNING UNTIL THE LAST
SECOND YESTERDAY AND TWEETING
OUT ASKING HER SUPPORTERS TO GET
IN LINE TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
IN LINE AT 7:00 A.M. PACIFIC TO
MAKE SURE THEIR VOTE COUNTED.
BOTH OPTIMISTIC, GIVING THIS
SPEECH, BOTH SAYING THAT THEY
COULD WIN, BOTH FEELING
CONFIDENT ABOUT WINNING.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> OUR POSITIVE ENERGY GOT US TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND WE ARE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT POSITIVE
ENERGY CONTINUES TO FLOW THIS
WEEK.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THIS DONE.
>> WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE THERE AND WE'RE
GOING TO WIN THIS RACE, WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE BACK NEVADA AND
TAKE BACK AMERICA.
>> Reporter: AND, ANDERSON, THIS
MIDTERM ELECTION HERE IN NEVADA
IS LIKE NO OTHER.
IN 2020 NEVADA WENT INTO A
UNIVERSAL VOTE MAIL BALLOT AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT EVERY
REGISTERED VOTER, ALL 1.8
MILLION UNLESS THEY OPTED OUT
GOT A BALLOT IN THE MAIL.
AS LONG AS THEY POSTMARKED THEIR
BALLOT YESTERDAY IT COULD GET
COUNTED UP TO SATURDAY AND SO WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THOSE
BALLOTS WERE PUT IN THE MAIL
YESTERDAY, ANDERSON, BUT WE KNOW
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
COUNTED, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
COUNTED UNTIL SATURDAY AND
THAT'S HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS HERE
IN NEVADA.
>> ROSA FLORES, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> IN ARIZONA TWO TRUMP-BACKED
REPUBLICANS ARE TRAILING THEIR
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENTS, BLAKE
MASTERS IS BEHIND INCUMBENT MARK
KELLY BY AT LEAST SIX POINTS IN
THE RACE FOR SENATE.
RACE FOR GOVERNOR IS A LOT
CLOSER.
SARA SIDNER IS LIVE IN PHOENIX
AT THE MARICOPA COUNTY ELECTIONS
CENTER.
WHEN DO WE EXPECT MORE RESULTS?
>> Reporter: LOOK, THEY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 300,000 VOTES LEFT
TO BE COUNTED AND THIS PROCESS
TAKES A LONG TIME BECAUSE HERE
IN ARIZONA THEY ARE VERIFYING
EVERY SINGLE SIGNATURE AND WE
WERE JUST TOLD BY THE MARICOPA
COUNTY ELECTIONS TABULATION
CENTER THAT THEY ARE ABOUT TO
START THAT VERIFICATION PROCESS
YET AGAIN.
THEY HAVE BEEN UP ALL NIGHT
TRYING TO COUNT ALL OF THESE
BALLOTS THAT HAVE COME IN.
A LOT OF THIS STATE AND A LOT OF
THIS COUNTY, WHICH IS THE MOST
POPULOUS COUNTY, VOTES BY MAIL
OR VOTES EARLY AND SO A LOT OF
THE COUNT HAS HAPPENED, ABOUT
60% TO 70% OF THE COUNT HAS
ALREADY HAPPENED, BUT THEY DO
HAVE ABOUT 30% TO GO AND THAT
INCLUDES ABOUT THOSE 300,000
BALLOTS, MANY OF THOSE WERE
MAILED IN, BUT THEY RECEIVED
THEM BY TUESDAY.
SO THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING JUST
IN THE BUILDING BEHIND ME, THEY
ARE STARTING THAT VERIFICATION
PROCESS AND WE WILL KNOW MORE
VERY, VERY, VERY SOON.
I DO WANT TO MENTION THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE CANDIDATES THAT
ARE UP FOR ELECTION AND THREE OF
THE CANDIDATES IN THESE REALLY
BIG RACES, SECRETARY OF STATE,
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE AND THE
SENATE RACE, THREE OF THE
REPUBLICANS IN THOSE RACES ARE
ELECTION DENIERS AND SO PEOPLE
ARE REALLY WATCHING THIS RACE
AND TWO OF THEM BACKED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY WATCHING THIS
TO SEE WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND IF
DONALD TRUMP HAD ANY KIND OF
INFLUENCE, WHETHER GOOD OR BAD,
THE REPUBLICANS ARE LOOKING AT
THIS AND SAYING IF THEY SEE THAT
THE MAJORITY OF INDEPENDENTS AND
THAT IS THE MAJORITY OF VOTERS
HERE, IF THEY SEE THAT THIS GOES
TO THE DEMOCRATS THEY WILL KNOW
THAT THE INDEPENDENTS MADE A
DECISION AND DECIDED TO GO
DEMOCRAT, BUT WE HAVE TO WAIT
AND SEE WHAT THE COUNT S
ANDERSON.
>> SARA SIDNER, APPRECIATE IT.
THE CONTENTIOUS SENATE RACE IN
GEORGIA COULD VERY WELL BE
HEADED FOR A RUNOFF.
INCUMBENT RWARNOCK IS LEADING
HERSCHEL WALKER BUT BY THE
THINNEST OF MARGINS.
JEFF ZELENY IS LIVE FOR US IN
MARIETTA, GEORGIA.
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE WAS CALLED
FOR THE INCUMBENT BRIAN KEMP.
WHAT'S THE LATEST ON THE SENATE
RACE?
>> Reporter: WELL, ANDERSON,
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE HERE
BETWEEN THAT GOVERNOR'S RACE AND
THE SENATE RACE.
IT'S REALLY ESSENTIAL BECAUSE
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP AS YOU SAID
WON PRETTY EASILY, AT LEAST BY
TODAY'S STANDARDS, OVER DEMOCRAT
STACEY ABRAMS BUT HERSCHEL
WALKER UNDERPERFORMED, REALLY
ACROSS THE STATE, BUT
PARTICULARLY IN THE SUBURBS,
LIKE HERE IN COBB COUNTY, JUST
NORTH OF ATLANTA AND OTHER
SUBURBS.
SO THE STATE OF PLAY THIS
MORNING IS BOTH CAMPAIGNS ARE
PREPARING FOR A RUNOFF, THAT HAS
NOT OFFICIALLY BEEN CALLED BY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
BUT ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
BRACING FOR THIS AND PREPARING
FOR THIS RUNOFF WHICH WOULD BE
DECEMBER 6th.
SO THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
18,000 VOTES SEPARATE RAFAEL
WARNOCK AND HERSCHEL WALKER BUT
EARLY THIS MORNING AS THEY
ADDRESSED THEIR SUPPORTERS THEY
ASKED FOR A LITTLE MORE TIME AND
PATIENCE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WHETHER IT'S LATER TONIGHT OR
TOMORROW OR FOUR WEEKS FROM NOW,
WE WILL HEAR FROM THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA.
>> IF YOU CAN HANG IN, HANG IN
THERE A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
JUST HANG IN THERE A LITTLE BIT
LONGER BECAUSE SOMETHING GOOD IT
TAKES A WHILE FOR IT TO GET
BETTER AND IT'S GOING TO GET
BETTER.
>> Reporter: SO EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE FOUR MORE SENATE RACES
IN THE COUNTRY STILL
OUTSTANDING, GEORGIA IS THE ONLY
ONE WHERE THERE ACTUALLY CAN BE
A REMATCH BECAUSE OF STATE
ELECTION LAW HERE REQUIRES THE
WHIPPING CANDIDATE TO RECEIVE
50% OF THE VOTE PLUS 1.
EVEN THOUGH SENATOR WARNOCK IS
IN THE LEAD THIS IS ALMOST
CERTAINLY GOING TO A RUNOFF,
FOUR MORE WEEKS OF CAMPAIGNING
HERE, ALL EYES WILL BE ON
GEORGIA IF CONTROL OF THE SENATE
HANGS IN THE BALANCE, WHICH IT
APPEARS THAT IT WILL.
>> FOR ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE
SICK OF POLITICAL TV ADS IN
GEORGIA, I THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO BE WATCHING THEM FOR A COUPLE
MORE WEEKS.
>>> I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WISCONSIN NOW WHERE REPUBLICANS
THE SENATOR RON JOHNSON IS A
HAIR AHEAD OF MANDELA BARNES
WITH 94% OF PRECINCTS REPORTING.
LUCY CAV THAOUUCY CAVANAUGH IS .
>> Reporter: POSSIBLY A SPLIT
TICKET.
IT'S BEEN A FASCINATING RACE TO
WATCH.
WE SAW SENATOR RON JOHNSON
INITIALLY CONSIDERED AS ONE OF
HIS PARTY'S MOST ENDANGERED
INCUMBENTS.
HE DECIDED TO RUN, MANDELA
BARNES THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR A
DEMOCRAT CHALLENGED HIM, HE WAS
A LITTLE AHEAD IN THE POLLS
LEADING UP TO THE ELECTION BUT
WE SAW THAT LEAD EVAPORATE.
NOW IT'S DOWN TO THE WIRE.
94% OF THE VOTE IN, JOHNSON
EDGING AHEAD BARNES BY NEARLY
32,000 VOTES, WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR SOME COUNTIES TO
FULLY COMPLETE THE NUMBERS, BUT
JOHNSON SORT OF DECLARING
VICTORY ALREADY, CAUTIOUSLY,
THOUGH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'VE LOOKED VERY CLOSELY AT
THE NUMBERS, WE FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT THAT THERE IS NO WAY
THAT THEY CAN REALLY MAKE UP
THAT GAP, BUT I'M NOT -- I'M NOT
GOING TO, YOU KNOW, DECLARE
VICTORY UNTIL ALL THE NUMBERS
ARE IN, BUT I JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU GUYS THE SENSE THAT THIS
RACE IS OVER.
>> Reporter: SO WE HAVE YET TO
HEAR FROM BARNES, HE HASN'T
SPOKEN YET, ALTHOUGH WE ARE
HEARING THAT JOHNSON MAY BE
MAKING A SPEECH IN THE NEXT HOUR
OR TWO.
AGAIN, THIS RACE HAS NOT BEEN
FORMALLY CALLED BUT IT'S NOT ALL
BAD NEWS FOR THE DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE THE INCUMBENT DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR TONY EVERS DID WIN, AT
LEAST ACCORDING TO CNN
PROJECTIONS, HE ALSO DECLARED
VICTORY YESTERDAY AND THAT IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT AT A TIME
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE HERE IN
WISCONSIN IS SEEKING VETO-PROOF
SUPER MAJORITIES.
IF JOHNSON DOES EDGE AHEAD AND
IS DECLARED THE WINNER, WE COULD
BE SEEING A SPLIT TICKET.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN 24
YEARS THAT WISCONSIN HAS SEEN A
DIFFERENT PARTY WIN FOR GOVERNOR
AND SENATE.
>> A LOT STILL IN PLAY.
LUCY KAFANOV, THANKS SO MUCH.